Що не хата - то парник і теплиця.
Це село Великі Копані на Херсонщині.
А відоме воно не лише тим, що тут кожен селянин вирощує на продаж городину.
І не лише найбільшим в Україні сільськогосподарським оптовим ринком.
Але й тим, що при владі тут самі лишень… жінки.
Дівчата, на нараду...
З цими словами керівниці усіх департаментів та відділів збираються до конференц-залу.
Тут проходять їхні щоденні ранкові зустрічі.
Голова ОТГ, керівниця комунального підприємства, амбулаторії, проєктна менеджерка -
і лише один чоловік. Чому так?
На посаду ми беремо по конкурсу і ви знаєте, що на конкурс чоловіки не подають свої заявки.
Я нічого поганого не хочу сказати про наших чоловіків, але так склалось,
що наші населені пункти - це пункти, де більшість людей зайняті вирощуванням сільськогосподарської продукції
і плюс те, що у нас є велики оптовий ринок, то наші чоловіки більше працюють на городах…
Валентина Костенко, вчителька за освітою, вже понад 15 років на керівній посаді.
Спершу як сільська голова Великих Копанів. І вже шість років як керівниця об'єднаної громади.
Це три села і понад 7 тисяч жителів.
Лише із децентралізацією Валентина Костенко відчула більшу свободу, бо, каже,
раніше до ідей жінок-лідерок чиновники вищого рангу ставились з упередженням.
Як це впливає?
Коли ми були підлеглими райдержадміністрації, то, як кажуть, на килим треба було.
То там відчувалось, що більшість чоловіків і кілька жінок. І ти себе не в тому кріслі відчуваєш.
А коли зараз, незалежні, ми не відчуваємо того, що ми жінки, різниці з чоловіками.
Ми керуємо. Все у нас добре.
Зокрема, жінки вигадали свою формулу, як заохотити молодих фахівців жити і працювати в селі.
Це не стільки конкурентна з містом заробітна плата, як власне житло та саморозвиток.
Приміром, сорокарічний херсонець Андрій Портнягін працював у сільській лікарні лаборантом.
Водночас у Великих Копанях бракувало сімейного лікаря, тож чоловіку запропонували пройти відповідні курси.
Майже рік навчання коштом громади, і тепер Андрій  - сімейний лікар.
Має понад півтори тисячі пацієнтів.
Коли я ще вчився в університеті, було упередження щодо роботи в селі.
Всі хотіли бути світилами обласних центрів.
Але у великих містах чимало лікарів і чи будеш ти там конкурентоспроможним?
Треба їхати в села. Тут є велика потреба в сімейних лікарях.
А ще цього року громада придбала лікарю помешкання.
Все, що треба, заїджай - живи.
Квартира не нова, і роботи тут чимало.
Втім, для медичного працівника це неоціненний подарунок.
Адже це його перше власне помешкання.
аку ж "формулу" застосували і до Андрія Пономаренка, 30-річного завідувача відділу культури.
Одружився на нашій дівчині, тобто наш зять став. І ми почали з дівчатками задумуватись…
Ми спочатку спостерігали. А потім підвернулось житло, таке, що ремонту не треба робити,
і ми  його прдбали і поїхали свататись, і Андрій Іванович сказав - добре.
Я не бачив таких випадків, де хтось міг би похизуватись,
що дають державну роботу плюс житло.
Я не бачив цього. І мені це приємно.
Розвитку культури у Великих Копанях приділяють чималу увагу.
Тут і до децентралізації діяв власний театр та хор.
Та коли в громади з'явилися власні кошти, культурна сфера розквітла ще більше.
Реставрували занедбанану будівлю колишнього радгоспу і відкрили Центр розвитку громади.
Щодня на різноманітні гуртки сюди з'їжджаються діти навіть із сусідніх ОТГ.
Тут і хореографія, і вокал, і підготовчі класи для дошкільнят.
Є власна студія звукозапису.
Кожне приміщення - це ще й історія успіху написання грантів.
Адже без донорської допомоги громаді розвиватись непросто.
Вся справа в тому, що в сільській місцевості дуже важко знайти вузьких спеціалістів
для органів місцевого самоврядування, проєктних менеджерів фактично не можливо знайти.
Я проходжу підвищення кваліфікації,
і це все дає можливість розвивати нашу громаду, зростати як спеціаліст і вигравати проєкти.
З останніх великих грантових перемог -
відкриття колись культового для села кафе "Ромашка", приміщення якого роками занепадало.
Шніцель, гороховий суп, борщ, курячий суп і випічка..
Коштом громади кафе реставрували, а за грант купили сучасне обладнання.
Тепер селяни можуть дешево і смачно поїсти, а ще весілля відгуляти.
Та найцікавіше те, що належить кафе комунальному підприємству "Великокопанівське".
Підприємство, створене одразу після децентралізації, спершу відповідало
переважно за, так би мовити, традиційні комунальні послуги:
вивіз сміття зі шкіл і садочків, технічне обслуговування каналізацій,  ремонт доріг.
Тепер же сфера його послуг розширилась.
Це й робота кафе “Ромашка”, і шкільної їдальні.
Харчування в школі вирішили забрати з балансу закладів освіти.
Це покращило меню і якість послуг.
Тож і виходить, що керівниця комунального підприємства - Лариса Самойлова, фахівчиня широкого профілю:
то якість їжі контролює, то за ремонтом тракторів стежить.
Останнє без підтримки чоловіків вдається нелегко.
Хлопці допомагають, якщо поломка, то ми спілкуємось, всі разом працюємо, бо сама б я в цьому не розібралась.
Кричу кожен день з ранку і до вечора - така у мене професія.
Планів розвитку Великокопанівської ОТГ чимало, як і проблем.
Найбільша з них - дороги. Адже 90% вулиць тут не асфальтовані.
А через найбільший сільськогосподарський ринок потік автомобілів не стихає навіть вночі.
І хоча громаді вдається заробляти щороку до 20 мільйонів гривень,
втім, цього бюджету не вистачить на асфальтування й однієї вулиці.
Тож поки ці кошти йдуть на соціальні потреби громади.
Це, зокрема, закупівля сучасного обладнання для шкіл, де віднедавна почали навчатись діти з інвалідністю.
Придбання обладнання для амбулаторій і лікарні.
В ОТГ під керівництвом жіноцтва впевнені, що саме якісні освіта, медицина та культура
дозволять покращити якість життя селян і зберегти відтік молоді.
Наразі рецепт, схоже, спрацьовує.
Щорічно лише 5% людей залишають громаду, і це переважно ті, кому не вдається заробляти на землі.